So yeah, mine's a little
bit different from what you
have heard.
No models here,
just a very presentation.
So Swasti's a health
resource center.
We are based in Bangalore.
We were established in 2002 by
a team of passionate individuals
working in the area
of public health.
So basically we work,
we look into the problems
plaguing the public health and
we find out solutions, we build
models to solve these problems.
And we either pilot those models
ourselves, we look for grants,
or we work with partners
working on the ground and
we provide technical
support to them.
So all the areas that we've all
been last 12 figures is sexual
for different health rights.
So HIV was one of the earliest
program that is on and
we can do what.
In HIV, we support the national
government and the programs.
We work on life skills for all,
we worked with the factory
workers and factories of women
working factories, wash, water,
sanitation, hygiene
is a big area for us.
Then, technology in public
health is something that has
been cross cutting for
all the themes.
We ensure that we bring
technology in all the work
that we do.
Safety, security and justice
is an important work for us.
We look at sexual harassment,
how do we prevent
harassment in workplaces.
And social protection, how do
we help the communities get
access to the [INAUDIBLE]
schemes that government has, and
how do we [INAUDIBLE] from that.
So [INAUDIBLE] 400,000
[INAUDIBLE] communities,
in the last 15 years.
And for us the vision is
[INAUDIBLE] healthy people,
and how do we do this?
We ensure that
communities get access to
the most number of options,
not limited by choices.
So what we've over the last
working 15 years if
we've heard a lot of partners
people working on the ground
that when working in particular
areas, if someone is solving
the problem of diabetes, someone
is solving the problem of HIV.
But then I think the team
was frustrated by
areas where not everything
is getting solved, so
if you solve one problem there's
and the problem creeps up.
So how do we bring
all of this together?
So last one year,
we're working on a model
called Invest For Wellness.
What we realized is to
solve this problem what
we require is someone who works
dedicatedly in not just one
particular area, but works with
the family in all of the areas.
What we require in truth is.
We need to bring in financing,
medical science,
behavioral science,
social science and
technology together to solve
the problems of public health.
How do we do that?
So we have a local
community health center to
walking with the families,
who is responsible for providing
[INAUDIBLE] by 75 days a year.
It's responsive, friendly,
trusted, quality, and
affordable and
accessible care to the members.
And so
I mean we have data from the and
we have prioritized some ten
conditions that we will work in.
And we will bring in partners,
we will bring in products
together and we will solve the
key problems of sanitation, air,
water, and food.
So I just started on the of
learning technology in the last
couple of years.
We have used the money for
data collection.
We have moved from paper-based
to ad-based data management.
We've developed tools for
engaging with
the community members.
We have developed multi
invention tools for
all the programs we have done.
We have developed by some
tracking platforms for
governments, for founders and
for foundations.
We've developed tools for doing
community feedback mechanisms
from communities and some of the
recent examples that I just want
to share with you
are our work in Taaras.
So Taaras is a Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation funded
program for sex workers.
And that program has been
running the last 15 years in
India and we've developed
a platform for not just but
the communities I think what
mentioned in the beginning.
How do we use community members
not as someone to provide data?
But I mean,
we interact with them, and
get data from them, and
not just form these mechanisms.
So we've developed mechanisms
where the head focus goes out to
the community members.
They talk to them.
It's not just asking what’s
the need, what's your age?
But you have them solve
their problems and then
in that process we collect data
on an app that we've developed.
So that app currently is
being used by our users.
And 48 districts in
of southern India and
it had live data for about
1,20,000+ community members.
And we have dashboards that
right from the community level,
to the district level, to the
state level, and national level.
So some of the features of this
Hyper-V there's one-to-one
engagement with
the community members, so
these are sex workers who face
incident from [INAUDIBLE].
Then this [INAUDIBLE]
Apple has a database of
all the SP Schemes that
the government has.
And depending on the gender
of the worker the state
the district, the schemes are
best for the community member?
And this app will also help them
apply for the schemes, it is
integrated with the national
portal for the government.
The second one I want to
share with you is Suyojana.
So this is something that we had
partnered with a company called
D-Tree based in Boston and
Karuna Trust in Bengal.
We had dug up the tools for
ANM, Auxiliary Nurse Midwives,
using decision tree models to
work in the area of maternal and
neonatal care.
So we had tried this
with 31 ANMs and
across 4 districts in Karnataka.
What we learned from this
is that adding the design
of the app is a very crucial
aspect of what we do.
Some of the challenges that
we've learned by bugging
technologies adding we need
to go beyond the direction.
I mean, at this area of work,
the team is still focused on how
do we move data region from
paper base to technology.
And authoring someone mentioned
that the field teams,
the help workers they're
not really tech-savvy.
Most of them are using
smartphones of the first time.
And it's very important to train
them in how to use a smartphone.
What happens if a scan goes bad,
how do you tell your phones.
So we are in India, but do we
work with tech companies and
their teams full of coders?
How do we translate
what we understand
in the development world?
How do they understand?
And marrying both sectors
is very important.
We have also found that
the hardware and software.
If you struggle with hardware
between the incongruencies
the phone should be able to
support web developing and
there is a lot of
frequent crashes.
When you update an app it has
to go to all the [INAUDIBLE]
workers.
And interpret the quality,
how do we ensure the database
[INAUDIBLE] field is top notch,
how do we ensure
that the field workers they know
what questions also we asked.
How do we ensure that there is
no noise coming in the data?
And some of the lessons
that we've learnt.
How do we consider base line and
an end line?
How do we build it up as we
interact with the community
members and we build it
up every by every step?
We want to learn that design
technology from the ground days
to ensure that
the technology's future-ready.
What it realizes, what you have
done something two years back,
we can not do
the same thing now.
So I mean, having a good design
to the base is very important.
And the community must really
feel that the technology's
something that is out
there to help them.
They often feel threatened
when they see a phone in front
of them.
So getting a good [INAUDIBLE] in
the community is very important.
And one of the most important
[INAUDIBLE] transparency.
The few locals didn't know that
[INAUDIBLE] national
office [INAUDIBLE].
So how do we prevent
[INAUDIBLE] technology.
And where do we see
use of AI right now?
So what we've learned is, if you
want to scale of we'll need of
technology, and how do we ensure
we're there where it's needed.
Finding in which households and
individuals are prone to be more
vulnerable and how do we bring
them and figure it out, and
not looking at the whole.
Understanding the behavior
pattern of the users.
I mean, how do we track the user
using that properly, and how do
we send out special customized
notifications to them?
For us, household units.
We don't look at individual
members, so how do we
which households are prone
to certain kind of problems?
And then segmenting them and
being proactive and
not reactive.
And understanding so first we're
looking primary case and so
understanding the [INAUDIBLE]
diagnosis and
how are we getting them.
So how do we ensure that we
learn from the symptoms and
again we more proactive and
not reactive.
That's it, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]